hey this is presh talwalkar
let's consider geometric series which
has k terms and a common ratio r so we
start out with one and then we're going
to multiply that to get the next term
which is r
we then multiply r by the common ratio r
again to get r squared and we continue
and we keep adding terms all the way
until we get to the kth term which is r
to the power of k minus 1.
to find the sum we do a neat little
trick we multiply the sum
by the common ratio r
look at what this will do to each term
the first term one becomes r
the second term r becomes r squared
and the pattern continues
we've essentially shifted over the
summation and we get one more new term r
to the power of k
we now subtract the second equation from
the first
this will cancel out many terms
in particular we cancel out the r's we
cancel out the r squares we cancel out
all of these middle terms and we cancel
out r to the power of k minus 1.
when we subtract the two equations the
only terms that survive
are 1 and minus r to the power of k
we now factor s sub k on the left hand
side
and then we divide both sides by 1 minus
r
and that's the formula that we want
the sum of a geometric series will be
equal to a fraction where the numerator
is one minus r to the power of k and the
denominator is one minus r
sometimes it'll be convenient to
multiply the numerator and denominator
by negative one and that's the formula i
used in this video which is r to the
power of k minus one all over r minus
one
one more note let's suppose we have a
geometric series that starts out with
some other term a
we then essentially multiplied each term
by a so that we'll also multiply
our sum by a so these would be our
formulas if our geometric series started
out with the term a
for completeness i'll mention that if we
were dealing with an infinite series
if our common ratio has an absolute
value of less than 1 then we could find
the sum of the infinite series by taking
the limit as k goes to infinity
and this will become the well-known
formula of the sum of the geometric
series which is a divided by 1 minus r
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description